you and i have wasted more hours of our
life doing uh
beetles doing you love to do we're
obsessed we're obsessed
we're both obsessed with it and uh we
both like to play guitar and we both
know all those songs we know everything
we know way too much about it
but then you will start talking about as
mccartney
and you'll do mccartney describing
what's going on in the world i
i like to visit the beatley voice uh
when things are dark
because i don't think you can you could
take almost any news story
and filter it through the b league paul
mccartney liverpudlian colloquialisms
and it comes out more positive
right just think of any story anybody in
the audience any story
that's kind of dark or not uh the
pandemic
well you know it's you know this little
thing came around you know
this little thing it's a little thingy
and it sneaks in your body
you know but the good news is we came up
with a with a vaccina
you know we got a jabber we got a jabber
and what the does is you know it goes in
your body and it
tells the cells to make themselves all
spiky so they look like a corona virus
you know i've seen you
i see you around here again i know what
to do
so it makes you it makes me so happy
yeah yeah suddenly it's not so scary
we got a jabba we got a jabba
you used to do uh you once were doing
mccartney explaining to
uh lenin and and like lennon's up in
heaven and he checks in with paul every
now and then and he's explaining
to mccartney is trying to explain rap
and rap stars kanye west and lenin
doesn't understand what mccartney is
talking about that came from really
always wanting john lennon and paul
mccartney to to hook up and talk about
how brilliant they were together you
know so i just did it for my own
amusement but
it's like how you doing paul i'm doing
fine jon how are you
that's great you know how's it going
down there who's greater made a record
with the kanye west you know who's
who's the kanye west
he's a talky singer you know does he
have a good gal behind him i had yoko
yeah he's got a great gal by the network
used to wait a minute this bit's two
years old
[Laughter]
okay i'll adapt on the fly he had a nice
girl but she's you know she flew the
coop you know but she had a
she's so she's really terrific what did
she do well she's a sort of a you know
she takes pictures of a bottom
[Laughter]
what do you mean it's not a normal
bottom john it's a bottom 2.0
it's like it's like god made a fanny and
attached a person as an afterthought
it was 2019. it's a little dated now
it's good stuff though
you